all right everybody i'm
here i am back to streaming it's great
to be back not only on youtube and
twitch but also facebook we were not
able to be on facebook last week for the
rnc
because um the copyright
elements because of the music were a
real problem
so i'm glad to be back on facebook as
well
and um we have uh what is
surely to be a very humiliating and
bizarre
presentation from donald trump we're
waiting for him i guess to arrive in
north carolina
and then schedule to say some things at
the top of the hour so we're going to
keep an eye on that but i have
so much to talk to you about so much to
tell you about
as you as you all may know many of you
haven't noticed and that's fine
but some of you noticed that i did not
stream since the rnc on thursday night
and it's because i was
my brain was in recovery mode from
taking in so many high level ideas
and i just took a little bit of time off
and on monday when i would have been
streaming i was in transit back to
oh no am i muted again oh no i'm muted
no i'm kidding i know i'm not um i was
in tr when i would have streamed this
week on monday i was in transit back
to out of the bunker and back to the
studio so in any case
i'm here now is the point and we're
going to hear from trump at the top of
the hour but i wanted to start a little
bit early because i have so many things
to discuss
now this is very interesting i had
a perfect phone call yesterday with my
youtube rep
and he explained to me that
people at youtube are very aware
of the david pakman show streams and
during the rnc we actually beat out
okay on some of the nights our stream
meaning you
right i mean i didn't do any i didn't
show up and watch you showed up and
watched
we beat out the young turks for our rnc
coverage
the young turks have like four or five
million subscribers or something
we beat crooked media which i think is
like the pop
is it pod save america with john favreau
i think that's crooked media anyway
they're huge they have huge
institutional money
but listen to this on on at least one of
the rnc nights
we beat the trump youtube channel
more people on a particular night
watched the rnc
on this youtube channel instead of
through the trump youtube channel so in
any case
people at youtube were going craz they
were they were up in arms
i guess they actually they almost
destroyed
youtube headquarters because they saw
how well our streams were doing and
people were going crazy three people
reportedly pulled their hair out and are
now on rogaine
um it was it was absolutely insane so in
any case
the streams are doing really really well
and it's great to be back and of course
we had
our best month in a year on twitch
in august which was beautiful by popular
demand i'm keeping subscriber numbers on
screen as you can see above my head
so a lot of very very exciting
things going on now i do also have
oh forkbom says happy birthday david via
super chat which i appreciate my
birthday's not for months but i still
like it
uh let me actually answer a few super
chats just before we move on also
oceanova subscribed on twitch and says
do i think foreign powers are trying to
exert influence via reddit
yes specifically the sanders for
president subreddit that i don't know
but certainly they are using reddit
that's absolutely for sure
um and before i fall too far behind i
also want to thank andrew olson who's
new member number one today at
joinedpakman.com
just kicking us off okay other super
chats matt
chavez says what's the likelihood of the
electorate in red states still voting
for trump
if the majority in their state goes to
biden by only a small amount
i don't know that i understand the
question how likely
is it that the electorate votes trump if
most people vote biden
i'm sorry i don't know but i think the
message is we have to fight for every
vote
for every single vote that's important
chakuseki says hey dave what do you
think has more
strokes donald trump's miserable golf
game or his good brain
i'm going to opt out of commenting on
that because later today i have a very
strong
clip on the trump mini strokes
allegations and i don't want to get
ahead of myself
sunil wani says hey david love the
content couldn't get through it without
you
also why do your videos always get ads
from the epoch times
we have no control over the ads jeffrey
geltman says glad you're super happy
about how well you're doing but i still
don't have access to the only fans i'm
starting to think something is up
remember there is no only fans
there is a cameo cameo or or i
sometimes i call it cameo but i tend to
call it cameo
okay bronx bjorn says david pakman out
of the basement disappoints america
again
donate to trump now for 600 match tired
of these emails
i get those all the time and you know
what's crazy my email account
has automatically started flagging the
emails from trump talking about how he
desperately needs me to donate a dollar
they've automatically started to be
flagged as
spam which i think is accurate quite
frankly i think that's perfectly
accurate
scrubby bubble says happy birthday david
remember when you said you might get a
million
buy the election i haven't
i have an incredible update for you in
fact let's take a look at socialblade
you will now see that socialblade is
able to issue a projection
that we will be at one million
subscribers
on october 3rd a full month
before the election if we can keep it
going
we're at 9.79 right now
set thousand obviously 979
000 and we are
slated to hit by october 3rd
and we're slated to hit 50 000 by the
way on twitch
very soon as well which i think is going
to be really really important for us
okay wait i had a bunch of different
things for you i do have
memes i also am going to be debuting the
david plosman
shuffle which is an incredible
compilation video by one of our viewers
named ryan
so i'm going to get that uh i'll get to
that at some point do people want
other memes as we say first do you want
trump unleashing a brutal attack on
bagged soup if you can imagine or do you
want the plasman shuffle what do people
want i'll just
take it's going to be an informal survey
of the chat
people are some people are saying yes to
everything i'm going to do everything
but we we have time i don't know what
the order is going to be
a lot of people want soup
plasma shuffle soup memes
video first people want everything okay
let's just let's do soup first let's get
soup out of the way
um here oh wait a second no no no
i have a letter hack this is not really
meme worthy but
this is the latest seinfeldization of
sam cedar versus david pakman to 1
million
this is i guess i'm newman because i'm
wearing the postal
jacket and sam is jerry
hello pacman hello sam so there's not
actually animosity between us and in
fact i don't know that i should say this
because it's sort of giving you a peek
behind the curtain
but sam has already recorded a
congratulatory video on 1 million we
have to plan these things in advance
so sam has already recorded his
congratulations to me
and i have it it's just we're not going
to use it until
until it's time which i think is fair um
okay here is trump
launching a brutal attack on soup okay
this was from july 31st but it was
basically
publicized yesterday and then they have
cans of soup
soup and they throw the cans of soup
that's better than a brick because you
can't throw a brick it's too heavy
but a can of soup you can really put
some power into that right right
and then when they get caught they say
no this is soup for my family
they're so innocent this is soup for my
family
uh it's incredible and you have people
coming over with bags of soup big bags
of soup
have you guys ever bagged soup now i've
seen manishevits
soup packets it's sort of a bag
in the sense that you know you mix it
with your broth
and spices i guess but bags
i've seen bags of wine i've not seen
bags of soup
and they lay it in the ground and the
anarchists take it and they start
throwing it
at our anarchists
cops at our police and if it hits you
that's worse than a brick because it's
got
force force it's the perfect size it's
like
made perfect and when they get caught
they say no this is just
soup for my family soup and then the
media says this is just these people are
very very innocent
they're innocent people these are just
protesters
isn't it wonderful to allow protesting
and by the way the media knows it better
than we do so anyway i mean you know
what is true is i've been suspicious
i've been suspicious of alphabet soup
for a long time
it could spell disaster if you don't
handle it correctly in a literal sense
you understand what i'm saying
but um no i i don't know soup to me is
not dangerous i mean certainly i've read
about a bad chowder
but um you know i don't think uh
soup is really dangerous and uh
consummates
in particular bisques are completely
inoffensive to me
so that's trump on soup okay
let's get now should we do the plaz the
david plasman shuffle it seems we still
have time
let me do a couple other just thank yous
dj saint trujian has subscribed with
prime
goku has subscribed with prime
we have new member number two my
ab marker i don't know if i'm
pronouncing that correctly
and corbin paradis is new member number
three consider yourselves invited by the
way to come to my website
at joinpackman.com and grab a membership
i'll do a couple other super chats then
we'll debut david plosman shuffle
unknown prodigy says what happens to
your viewership when biden gets elected
people like watching you the most to
alleviate the trump train wreck so
i discussed this in fact with my youtube
rep if joe biden were to win
first of all between november and
january it'll be even more trump
craziness
january we will be a a channel that
holds biden accountable to the things he
has promised and
there will be untold amounts of
disgusting pond scum bottom feeding
republican obstruction to cover if biden
is president
so we're going to have our hands very
full we're going to be juggling a lot if
joe biden
becomes president so those those are
some of the things that we are
thinking of um
cc has grabbed a youtube subscription
whoa hold on a second a lot happening
here
cynical insomniac says heads up y'all
i'm in ohio trump will win it
tiffany hall says david if you could ask
trump any one question and he couldn't
lie what would you ask him
did you really want to be president
insight of the ages says putting the
headline ahead of the event is a clear
sign of gaslighting who is holding the
lantern david
thank you kyle hopper says one of our
voters named kyle
oh one of our viewers okay all right
kyle hopper is the person who made the
david plosman shuffle
let's just get to it i was laughing out
loud at this earlier today
i present to you with no further delay
let's just make sure okay we still have
time
this is the david plosman shuffle
take a look at this uh let's see what
else we've got here
the david pakman
[Music]
by the way this is bernard purdy
fantastic drummer
[Music]
so you've heard me say it this is not a
rehearsal
right very very important stuff because
this could get
really ugly really quick ow
now
the big big big big big big question
you all see what's going on i see what's
going on we're not going to fall for it
these bizarre
semantic games philosophical black holes
that people are getting we're just not
going to bite
i would return the ballot as soon as
possible
if you're mailing it if you have the
ability to drive it to a ballot box
i would do that as well and that's
actually my plan
make sure you have a plan that makes
sense based on what's happening in your
state
based on where you can drop off ballots
in your state
and don't make plasma out of nowhere
gets me every time
your plan on the basis of a false sense
of security from this announcement
that's the most important
message i think oh man
[Music]
it's the best
we have to just vote early early early
but it's too close
it's too risky we really need donations
of the plasma
he and i will have to make a decision
about how and when i send in my ballot
and assume nothing going into november
every single voter i
i apologize i know i say this a lot yup
every single voter
should act as if their vote could turn
your state from one candidate to the
other
which is to overwhelm the vote to such a
degree
that none of these bamboozlings and lies
actually help
donald trump to get reelected i was born
in argentina
[Music]
what we have to make sure we do is to
vote participate keep the pressure on as
far as the post office keep the pressure
on as far as
vote by mail and fundamentally the
question is
do you want to remove trump enough that
you will vote for joe biden
it's going to be a turnout battle and
specifically it'll be turned out in key
states
which will decide who wins it's
convalescent plasma
crawl over broken glass to vote november
so my ethnicity is ashkenazi jewish
right our
focus needs to be getting out the vote
and making sure that we vote
authorization
for a treatment known as convalescent
plasmas a wide array of effective
treatments
including a powerful antibody treatment
known as convalescent wasp i i know you
guys are
too smart but why would we take any
chance
all right we're going to cut it there i
don't want to show you
the the entire thing right now but it is
killer
it is absolutely killer so we're going
this entire video
with the full there's like an extra
minute which i'm not going to show you i
have to keep the mystery going to some
degree um
we are going to save it for when we
publish it it has not been
published yet okay i mean okay ryan has
it on his channel
but we have not yet published it and
what my favorite moment
is this moment right here a wide array
of
effective treatments including a
powerful antibody treatment
known as convalescent wasp that's just
the best
uh okay so that is that i'm not showing
you
any more anymore today and we will be
publishing that very very strongly
to our youtube channel but um
uh wait a second kyle did i
did i say the name wrong i said ryan oh
wait a second
hold on a second
ryan right it's kyle okay it's not ryan
kyle is the person who made it and it's
kyle hopper
who's right there and okay i think we
figured out who did that video so
uh it's extremely extremely good
okay continuing on um
let me just get other memes out of the
way just to get these done
so this is a beautiful one who works
harder to earn your subscription
is it deep fake six-pack
david pakman or is it sam cedar
okay you make the decision and then you
decide
where you want to sign up uh david
versus the colossus
as you can see here the battle for a
million subscribers
a sort of david versus goliath
stylized poster of some kind
um and we are getting very very close to
the million
and then lastly uh the beatles a hard
day's night this was
whoa hold on this was the day where i
had the uh
beatles haircut as you can see and
really fitting right in there with i
think this is paul right this is paul
over here
and this is uh is that ring
actually i'm not sure is that george
harrison or ringo i'm not sure but
anyway there i am so those are other
memes
that i have and remember you can always
send me your memes through the website
contact form
david davidpakman.com for very special
elements that you need to get to me
people in disagreement about whether
that's
george or ringo okay very good
um let's see what else we've got going
on here oh other people i don't want to
miss anybody else who has signed up
rex fleischer is new member number four
today
max lindell is new member number five
ethan pape is new member number six
as we see trump arriving becky castillo
is number seven
and dominique and kristen jaegee are
together
new member uh new members number eight
remember that we do have a coupon code
2020 now
membership is the number one funding
source
for our program and i would invite you
to go to joinpakman.com grab yourself
a membership i will thank you and it
will be a beautiful
beautiful event as donald trump arrives
here
unclear if he will be speaking right
away um
what a moment what a moment uh thanks to
joshua
1977 for subscribing over on twitch as
well as
ansel soul ball bearings up
nup king pazzo criminal
clertus kind of like a version of cletus
i guess clertus
all signing up and supporting this is
donald trump in north carolina
north carolina let's continue on with
some super chats that are coming in
kyle asks if trump wins can democrats
impeach for the
hatch act violation uh not going to
happen
it's just not going to happen rdx devin
nunes's cow
says a vote for biden is a vote for
trump lol
that certainly is not true it looks like
the cameraman was knocked down
uh hopefully they're able to stand up
and get the camera refocused again
uh does seem like light cloud cover in
north carolina not super useful but i
guess
a curiosity nonetheless
austin smith says do you think the
narrative around joe oh boy what's going
on here
do you think the narrative around joe
biden's cognitive decline on social
could be attributed to misinformation
from russia and other countries
yes very much so here is trump
clapping for the crowd and doing a fist
pump uh
as you can see not a mask in sight not
i don't think i see a single mask here
um
no not see i'm seeing a beret
but not a single mask here so we're
continuing to keep an eye on this
upcoming event that we are going to hear
from donald trump i would expect a lot
of crazy things
donald trump taking the mic let's listen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
this is the most important election
because we're running against people
that have got some big issues they've
got some big
big problems just don't go crazy
and as you know uh
[Music]
just so you guys know this is not
actually the event this is just trump
grabbed a mic on the way to the event
everything of the audio and video are
atrocious
uh we have to do what we're doing the
country's coming back really slowly
i'm going to say hello
[Music]
what's trump doing
right there
okay so i guess this is a campaigning
this is what you would call campaigning
i'm not really sure so trump gonna walk
around a little bit and i guess
talk to people um and then we're going
to um
then presumably the event is going to
start at some point green party trevor
asks whether i saw david blaine's
ascension stun
i didn't i didn't but what um i did hear
about it producer pat told me a little
bit about it
um i do want to say thanks to multibeast
for subscribing with seven months on
twitch prime
saying vote early vote often i say just
early
often is a little bit of a controversial
thing to say but i appreciate that
also thanks to everybody else including
greenman
who subscribed who says big and
beautiful subtember discounts on all
subs yes
my goal would be for this to be our best
month ever on twitch it is september i
don't know exactly what it means but i
got a few emails about it from twitch
and i guess everything is discounted
all subs discounted on twitch
very very exciting and i think that
that's something we should all
bear in mind eric says if trump had a
stroke they would have taken him to the
zoo
to use their veterinary veterinary mri
machine
because he wouldn't fit in a human one
ah that's below us that's beneath us
nah i'm not i don't like that lazarus
says do you like mexican food
yes if so what dish all of them
insight of the ages says why push the
hoax that trump didn't condemn
white supremacists at charlottesville
you were responsible for the violence i
don't know what you're
talking to me about right now tyler in
the residence says good luck today and
your pog champs match
yes 5 p.m east danny thompson says you
mentioned a story of something you did
from a past politicon that would be
controversial disappointing or shocking
would you consider sharing this as part
of our reward for youtube at one million
uh i don't know i don't know um
i'll think about that i'll think about
that pair tieren coming in from sweden
with
a thousand swedish kroner super chat
thanks pair
dominique jaggi has subscribed on
youtube jcvc says david congratulations
on getting into the championship bracket
for pogchamps i'm rooting for you
yeah i will be playing my quarterfinal
chess match in pog champs 2
today at 5 east to west
5 east to west i've done no preparation
i i took i just i've been taking time
off from everything
so i'm just gonna go in and play the
best chest that i can if i lose i'm out
of it
and that's going to be it so we will see
how that goes
thanks to cogento for subscribing on
twitch as well as boy meets
mini for gifting three subscriptions
which i appreciate
secret service furious with the camera
person let's see what's happening
[Music]
all right they're going with ymca once
again i guess during this
event and uh donald trump getting into a
vehicle and
very very soon we should be seeing him
at the
event which we are waiting for over on
the white house channel this was just
trump's
arrival and when that will start
supposedly a minute ago but as you can
see trump just yelling things at people
for now
so probably still going to be
a while s t wilson says keep up the good
work
thank you i appreciate that where did
that message go
try balsam says will ivanka ever be
potus you know i actually worry that
not only would donald trump's reelection
be bad because trump would be president
for four years
but i think it very much opens the door
to sliding right into
an ivanka or don jr candidacy
um in 2024 or 2028 which would be really
really scary they might take one
cycle off to make it seem a little bit
less dystopian but
we will see i want to say thanks to k
mcnamara who's new member number nine
today
diana shelton is new member number 10
and
lawrence ciderman is new member
number 11. you can sign up at
joinpacman.com
if you would like uh mcp
m.c peter feil says the name is pacman
erudite liberal not a caveman been
hating on trump since 2015
hey mega crowd check your hygiene
my hair is slick my wit is quick
if you vote red go back to the triassic
okay some kind of a poem
dalton haskins says if republicans keep
control of the senate do you think the
newly elected senators would break from
trump re-election being two years after
trump's term
too early to know i i try to focus on
one election at a time
jason nadal says tim poole announced
he's voting for trump based on his
agenda
is anyone surprised will you ever
interact with him again i have no idea i
haven't seen anything he's done or said
for months
and i haven't seen what tim said ali
says have you seen destiny's take on the
kenosha shooter he believes it was
self-defense
no i haven't seen that but that sounds
troubling
uh but i'd be glad to talk to him about
it
says really and or li really enjoy your
show david thank you
beetle okay so trump's arrival is now
over so i guess now we're waiting for
let's see foxy let's see if there's a
different live event here
um
not yet if anybody knows of a feed
other than the white house feed which is
not yet live that might be live in the
room where trump is going
let me know and i will uh
switch to that feed uh beetle greg says
it's george okay
big sos man florida prediction and a
long response as to why
i have no idea listen if if you forced
me to bet
money i probably say that
the polling is correct and
joe biden's going to win florida like if
you force me to bet but the truth is
it's so uncertain that i don't i don't
see any reason to even get i mean just
everybody's got a vote
we biden might win he might not that's
it
um okay
pair tiran says both of you are cute i
don't know who you mean
but i winning the covet debate against
alt-right people here
blocked from several by just posting
report vids from scientists keep the
fight up
pair we love you here i appreciate the
support thank you
rdx says russia didn't make joe talk
about little kids touching his leg hair
what normal person says that they're
both gone i actually
am having trouble even knowing what
people are talking about right now
katrina lania says i listen to you every
day truth
reigns supreme thanks katrina i
appreciate that
dominic richardson says do you ever
still think about the time
when you were in that documentary for
at-risk lgbt
teens yes i was once in a compilation in
a documentary
as a gay teen who had committed suicide
because i was bullied and i was like 27
years old at the time and i
you know i'm not gay and i wasn't
bullied and i was very much alive
so that was a weird moment let's see
um so do we have any other
live streams right now uh
let's see is now this live
i'm trying to figure i'm trying to see
if anybody is currently live
so we could switch to that feed trump
north carolina
um there's one that's local news which
is not
so good oh it looks like washing oh
beautiful washington post is live
let's get over to the washington post
stream
where we are awaiting donald trump's
arrival perfect okay here we go so now
we're not going to miss a minute
of it as it all happens
very good prior guy says david what's up
with the loud ass camera shutters at the
press briefings haven't they heard of
digital plasma
cameras yeah i don't know why it's so
loud it's really weird
it's really really weird super guy
says where is super guy what are your
thoughts on possible online voting i
have a clip about that on my youtube
channel
there are obvious pros and there are
some potential
downsides as well video on my youtube
channel about that
paris says you could at least read my
comment i did pair i did thank you
thanks to danielle charlie says are my
tax
tax dollars paying for trump's
loudspeaker rentals
quite possibly yeah quite possibly
frank asks frank drebin oh the great
frank drebin from police squad
david how many mail-in votes will be
lost or not counted will mail in voting
and trump's efforts to suppress result
in a trump win
i don't know the answers to that but i
have recorded a segment on today's
podcast which will be out in about an
hour
where i say that i if i'm totally honest
with you
voting in person is probably the most
likely to have your vote counted
correctly
now if you can vote early in person i
think that's preferable
november third voting listen everybody's
going to have to make a call i'm not
going to tell you what's safe and what's
not you have to assess your risk factors
for coronavirus and what's going on in
your state and decide
but i do think that there is a far more
significant chance of your vote being
counted and counted correctly
if you vote in person if if you vote in
person
keith jacobs says did you see biden
brought
bot keepamerica great.com i did not
i did not let me say
thank you to a couple of other members
alex
r is new member number 12. listen let me
just briefly mention as we are standing
by here
for uh for donald trump i would really
love it
i would really really love it if you
um like what i do honestly even if you
don't but you value it
you don't even need to like it or me
consider grabbing a subscription at
joinpakman.com
it's really cheap it's really easy
all but a few pennies of your payment
get to us
and it directly supports everything that
we are doing and we do have a coupon
code which is a really great coupon code
2020 now it saves you 66
off of the price of a membership we have
a goal of 25 members
i will thank everybody who signs up we
had some extremely powerful
sign up evenings during the dnc
and the rnc we want to keep it going
into september as we approach the
election so in all seriousness
we joke around a lot about membership
and
hype trains and super chats and all of
this different stuff
the system we control in total is the
one on our website
joinpakman.com and i do look forward to
welcoming
uh some some great people uh as they
sign up
let's see some people are saying destiny
wants to talk to me right now
yeah i don't know if we have time for
that because it's almost time
i'm covering this event i'll talk to
destiny anytime
when i don't have like something else
i'm covering but i think we're gonna
stick here
for now um yeah
let's do that so merrily says did i hear
that
trump was that the fbi was investigating
trump for being a russian spy
um no i did not hear that i did not hear
that
cogent oliver asks whether they know
what ymca is about
i do wonder why at every trump event
even if he's just walking by they play
ymca i've never really understood that
um i do want to say thanks to floppy225
for the twitch prime subscription as
well as
zeta rocks for the twitch prime
subscription and
shortbus who has subscribed with prime
as well
um maddie ice asks if there's any chance
joe kennedy runs for governor
anything is possible anything is
possible
mcpeterfeil says my name is pat oh
okay i already read that one same thing
again interesting
a user named david pakman says david
pakman says
he says he looked at the comment with a
mixture of curiosity and disgust
he would eventually love the comment
okay
thanks to micah lazarus says what's
easier for you to understand mexican
spanish or spanish from spain
that's interesting you know i think
to be perfectly frank by the way i
recorded an interview yesterday
in spanish with a great puerto rican
podcast
and my plan is after he releases it
i am going to subtitle it and upload it
to my youtube channel
and i think it'll be something different
i think it might be interesting for
people so that was recorded yesterday
and uh we're going to deal we're going
to put that up on our
youtube channel soon soon
jose vazquez asks how good is manu
ginobili
fantastic fantastic excellent excellent
basketball player
um oh did something happen with my mic
was there was there like a weird
staticky noise with my mic
because that happened earlier while we
were filming
oh weird what did it sound like what i
did was i
i unplugged and re-plugged everything
it's never happened to us before
like a blip
static like it wasn't plugged in
correctly that's weird yeah i i did
unplug and replug everything um
if it happens again let me know that's
really annoying though
distortion i could switch whoa what is
that
i could switch to a different voice
processor in case that was the issue i
have a backup voice processor with
identical settings
um but i'm not gonna do that right now
that's weird i i don't like that's never
happened to us before and it happened
multiple times today so that's that's a
concern
okay let's continue with various
messages that are coming in
um uh
let's see where were we here
jake feldman says david if you post a
job for a realtime factchecker on
monster.com i'll do the job for free
keep up the astounding work yeah i don't
know that we're doing i don't know that
that's a position we're opening in the
immediate
chris vins says hi sir david if donald
gets reelected would that make you worry
in terms of being
censored in any way doing your work in
independent media
not really no i don't think there's an
immediate threat
no james montalbano says did you see
today's story about trump jokingly
telling sarah sanders to take one for
the team with kim jong-un after he
winked at her
i did see it it's not really a story for
my show but i did see the story and it's
crazy
jason nadal says that i see the report
that showed the store owner trump
visited in kenosha wasn't the actual
current owner of the store
yes and i covered that on today's show
thanks to margin for the subscription
griffin smith says how big of a threat
do i think tom cotton is for 2024
way too early to tell if in 2012 someone
said donald trump is a huge threat to be
president in 2016 nobody would have
believed it
so i i think it's useless to speculate
in that way right now
we have a crazy number of new members
who just signed up let me thank some of
them
uh dean beaver is new member number 13.
brian levassour is number fourteen
jeremy sturk is number fifteen
sarah fisher is number sixteen sandrine
catris is number seventeen shura
sullivan is new member number 18.
hayden strabel is number 19
and carly weiss is number
20. might be wise i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly there's a few more
i'll do another batch in a little bit
uh anmo ammo doom
says i registered to vote for the first
time after lafayette square i'm 36
this election is big it is indeed very
very big
secret service looks like they are
taking their positions so we are
expecting donald trump very very soon
the white house feed has not yet gone
live but we're keeping a close eye
on this stream which is live
if you missed the top of the stream i
had the very exciting
i had two very exciting announcements
number one
that my youtube rep told me that during
the rnc
we beat out we were the top channel
on youtube for rnc um
we surpassed tyt in our live stream
coverage
and crooked media and we are now
slated to hit 1 million youtube
subscribers
on october 3rd we are just 31 days away
which is
crazy it's crazy that things have
exploded to this degree
so that's um very very exciting
and where are we right now we're at
about 9
79 we could get to 980
000 in an instant if a few of the people
watching on youtube
subscribe now it's free it's completely
free
we are just a few hundred subscribers
from 980
000 and i would love it if you helped me
along
in that let's see here
just go travel says dp how can you
criticize
trump for the way he tell lies and put
people down while you do the same in
your youtube title
before the event even happens it's it's
satire guys
it's become a thing to to have these
hyperbolic youtube titles like donald
trump
urgently speaks humiliates himself and
by the way
has trump ever spoken at one of these
rallies and not humiliated himself so i
would argue that
uh uh what you're saying it i just don't
care
you know we're we're all having a good
time here all right give me a break guys
richard lopez things are dark all right
my youtube titles are not the problem
how about the fact that the president
wondered about injecting
isopropyl to treat a virus that's the
problem
not my youtube titles
okay richard lopez says david if trump
wins or loses
is anyone else worried about the trump
kids running for potus me okay yeah so i
addressed that a few minutes ago and
that is a very very big concern
vincenzo dukes says drumpf really
showing his true colors
abusing his power in office and sending
very powerful
shots and blows across
the bow at poor defenseless soup
yeah trump taking his anger out on soup
thanks to mary for the subscription miss
kimberly says how many q anon phrases
do you think trump will toss his cult
today it's hard for me to say because i
don't know what those phrases are
i don't know too many q anon phrases
something somewhere says i never got a
sub
shout out um
okay well i don't know where you mean
you signed up but here's a shout out i
appreciate it
thank you to anonymousgifter who has
gifted a subscription to my twitch
channel on twitch to bernie sanders
thank you i appreciate that
couple of other new members to thank um
reginald jennings wow they're really
having trouble with the video at this
event
reginald jennings is new member number
21.
jeff lombard is number 22. francisco
castro is number 23.
daryl boscher is number 24. lindsay
miller is 25
amanda bunch is 26
ray curry is new member number 27 today
love it let's go for 50. we have some
signal loss
and still no live video from the white
house feed
it's really weird that the video is
having such problems
it looks sort of windy i guess maybe
that's part of the problem
i don't know but this is really really
strange
really strange that the video is so
problematic and judging from the amount
of activity
i would imagine that donald trump is
close to speaking
only 20 minutes late at this point in
time
we do have a video alarm
zest the african says go ed markey
doesn't have a perfect record
but he's great on climate wish alex
morse would have won as well
at rest in peace michael brooks an
all-encompassing message thanks zesty
noogie says did you read michael
brooks's book i ordered a copy
no i i i never really read anything in
that space i mostly read uh science
history and and sort of other things
christine has grabbed the soy boy
membership david eldridge says why you
conservatives always say the u.s was
founded on christian values
because they need to in order to justify
their worldview and policy priorities
what's going on with the video is
absolutely insane
i'm hoping that soon the white soon the
white house feed will actually start
because this is not what i would call a
high quality feed by any
by any stretch of the imagination
my god and the camera was like partially
covered by something
unbelievable is there a different feed i
could pick up does anybody know of a
different feed i mean eventually the
white house feed will go live
let's see what we've got trump
north carolina
so washington post is this one
there's a global news feed let me see
what that looks like
that one's offline wow
um yeah i'm not really finding any other
good feeds
maybe it'll normalize can't do news now
the hill has a feed but it seems to be
the exact same camera i don't know that
it's going to be any better for us
we'll keep that we'll keep that up as a
backup just in case
really weird a lot of interference a lot
of interference happening
um okay kyle b says do people actually
believed q anon garbage why doesn't
trump condemn it trump doesn't condemn
it because they like trump and trump
won't condemn anybody who likes him and
it is it is actually um a big enough
deal that i decided to have a media
matters researcher on the show yesterday
to talk about q anon alex kaplan
estimated
that uh q anon sort of numbers in the
millions but not the
tens of millions that was alex's
impression
yesterday make of it what you will the
full interview will be posted um
over the weekend super guy
says where did super guy's message go
super guy says what's with massachusetts
and republican governors
yeah massachusetts has a history of
being quite left but
electing republican governors and
um there are a number of reasons why
michael raleigh says trump giving a
political speech in front of a warship
even one that is that is a museum
seems to flirt with presidential norms
am i crazy well if you think this is bad
what about the rnc speech at the white
house
right that's that's really bad
just go travel says explain the reason
for your youtube title oh
trump humiliates himself every time he
does a rally
that's the explanation thanks to
lawrence for the subscription
thanks to shortbus who has gifted a
subscription over
on twitch which i am so thankful for
zest the african says the mic glitch
sounded like the og
moon landing radio it was only for a
mississippi second though
no worries yeah but i don't like it
because this is a pretty new mic as many
of you know i recently switched from the
evr e20
to the shure sm7b and if the prop you
know
i've had all of this exact equipment for
years never a single problem
i switched the mic all of a sudden i
sound like the moon landing audio
that's not good that's not good all
right we've had signal loss again let's
try going over to a different feed now
this feed is from the oh they're having
the same issue yeah so it's it's some
kind of master video feed issue
and the white house feed has still not
started interestingly enough
running very very late jane womanpower
says so happy i opened my youtube and
there you are covering a live stream
thanks so much for keeping the sanity
while covering trump thank you l mcvicar
says that was a straight stranger than
fiction moment back there
don't worry i caught it l-o-l-b-z
david's
i don't know what that means i'm
uncertain about that
d campbell says yay spanish content
finally can't wait for more excelende
felicidades thank you yeah if you missed
it yesterday i recorded an
interview in spanish it was in spanish
from the standpoint of language
and once the host uh posts it
to their channel he gave me the go-ahead
to post it to my channel and i will be
posting it with
um subtitles so everybody will be able
to understand
the the conversation
jake coburna says can you and anthony
fantano do a youtube video or interview
soon i'd be glad to do something with
fantano
anytime thanks to pups theme and richard
for the subscriptions
friendly fire says what what do you
think of australia censoring lockdown
protests i'm not aware of that i didn't
know that that happened
so i wouldn't be able to say too much
about it christopher
and nicholas have grabbed youtube
memberships
yabbitz says honolulu pearl harbor would
be
far better as america's first world war
ii
heritage city in my opinion
corey price has subscribed chris says
how can trump win without the black vote
uh well he won in 2016 without the black
vote i guess that's mostly
that the proof is in the pudding so to
speak
bumper miss grabbed a subscription the
glaive says how do you hold real
conversations about policies and
politics
in an era where misinformation is
debated as if it were real on the
24-hour news
cycle right and in fact this came up in
the interview that i did on the spanish
language podcast yesterday which is
it's great to have differences of
opinion and to explore them
but if we can't even agree about the
basic facts as a jumping off point for
those
opinion differences it's very difficult
to do much at all
and that is exactly right that is
exactly right
i don't know that you can thanks to
jamie for the super chat
attila says good game for the chess
match when is the next one
today at 5 pm i have a pog champs
match-up
anita not going to fall for it but anita
says this program
is about unsolved mysteries whenever
possible the actual family members and
police have participated in recreating
the events i don't know what anita
is talking about i really don't
very very unusual message
leica says let me give you a coffee
break on me david right well you know
five pounds
now that i'm just you know at home i
have my own espresso machine and i've
estimated that a cappuccino is about 45
cents
from the standpoint of coffee beans and
milk so you've really given me like 10
coffees worth there
people standing up it's i'm guessing
it's been announced that there's an even
longer delay now happening
trump of course scheduled to speak half
an hour ago
and um well that was 30 minutes ago
as you can tell he's not yet speaking
lazarus says i'm from san diego now
living in krakow poland
love watching your show i think you're
the best one thank you
n lindsay says even when trump gets
forced out of office his base will still
be listening to him
exactly i've made that point recently
and it is a very important point
that means senators and congressmen will
still be
scared of his tweet we will have to deal
with trumpist uh
sympathizers in the house and senate
and just in the general population for a
very long time
for a very long time thank you to mommy
chickson
as well as sneaky gaming for the twitch
subscriptions you guys
are subscribers 1352
as well as 1353
on twitch by popular demand i'm now
keeping the twitch subscribers on
screen people seem to like that people
seem to like them
um okay jf gambi says i'm having soup
tonight don't call the police
hope it's matzo ball other super chats
coming in
uh frank drebin says has a civil war
begun are these protests the starter to
the main course of violence in november
looking at this from across the pond
really worried i have a video uh on
friday coming out about that where i go
in in detail into that
mada says there should be more talk
about trump biden
in terms of administration picks kyle
talks about how bad trump versus
biden is but nobody is addressing how
would biden
administration picks be better than
trump's betsy devos etc it should help
people vote for biden
very well said very well said the trump
cabinet
is a disaster and the biden cabinet
would at least be a return to some sense
of normalcy
completely agree with you david goris
says did you hear that the q anon leader
is also the owner of 8chan
uh i did not i did not bay photo says
i'm always fascinated by the visual
elements whether it's
washing machines or navy ships trump
always needs some sort of elements of
patriotism
yeah i don't know that a washing machine
is patriotic i mean i guess having clean
clothes
um is sort of militaristic in some sense
maybe that's the connection i'm not
totally sure
but yeah always have visual elements
just go travel says i support biden but
i get angry
when the trump hardcore fans are biased
and already beforehand criticize biden
and what are you doing i'm starting to a
little bit lose the thread of just go
travel super chats i'm not i'm not
really sure
mada says i said kyle because kyle makes
comparisons between
biden trump but never addresses
administrations
was wondering if you could call it out
and talk about each possible department
with trump versus biden yeah i think we
will do a uh sort of cabinet
uh not kind of a cabinet what would it
be
wrap-up or analysis i think that that
would be interesting
other people i want to thank because
they signed up on my website and they
are really great people
uh rollin prince is new member number 28
today
nico menopache
is new member number 29 today
looks like things are sort of happening
here
okay lorraine
lorraine thames is new member number 30
today
jason wharton is number 31 abe
baginski is number 32 elaine
perry is new member number 33 and jacob
zizka is new member number
34. it does look
maybe like the secret service agents
that were with trump
at the landing are now here which maybe
is a sign that we are expecting donald
trump soon
um but who knows should i be recognizing
this guy i don't know who that is maybe
some of you guys know
okay heather hank says why haven't
families been
vocal about bounties it is surprising
that that has not gotten more attention
yeah steve calhoun says does trump
qualify for the biggest mass murderer in
usa history probably not but
quote it is what it is yes that that is
a direct quote from trump
prior guy says tammy joe
you can pet that dog pet dat dog
i don't know what that's about i have no
idea what that's about
um yeah okay
so i see people in twitch chat telling
me to talk to destiny right now
trump trump is about to come out so
we're not gonna do uh we're not gonna do
that right now but i'll talk to destiny
soon if people want me to antis weeble
as well as nolan and sneaky gaming
are new members on twitch mommy chickson
also has subscribed on twitch which i
appreciate
the video blacking out or browning out
as the case may be
just moments from the start of what it
seems like is going to be donald trump's
uh
speech today really terrible video
coverage from this event
really really bad people are standing
and taking pictures now
so i i wonder if they're taking pictures
of trump
uh but it's all very strange
very very strange that it is something
from what i understand it's only a
five-minute ride from where trump landed
to this event that may be wrong but uh
it's been a long time
it's really strange miss kimberly says a
couple big
q anon phrases are a light at the end of
the tunnel and the invisible enemy
trump will toss those out there in an
awkward repetition i didn't know the
invisible enemy was a q anon thing
i'm not sure about that ammo
doom whoa where did ammo doom go
ammo doom said
uh 2024 no more seniors
patty says david please forgive my
ignorance what is the red white flag to
the right on the stage
i have no idea maybe that's the state
flag of north carolina
it does there's a c on it let's see
what's going on here
i guess something is happening guys i
don't really know
super guy says covid loves trump rallies
no masks
anywhere megan gattis says
you and secular talk are my favorites
love your live streams thank you i
appreciate that
keegan says lots of biden signs out in
fort lauderdale
i know it's anecdotal but hopefully a
good sign for november love your channel
let's hope so
oh this is mark meadows right is that
mark meadows right here
i believe it is trump's chief of staff
horrible horrible person
nobody knows okay maybe it's mark
meadows all right
very good
uh this by the way
i expect that trump is going to be a
disaster during this speech
because he's he's going to come out
extremely fired up upward i'm expecting
upper trump
jacob dixon says there's a preamp called
cloud lifter
got one right here that you can use that
should solve your shore problems worth
it since the mic is really nice no no
i've got a cloud lifter
here it is see it in the corner of the
screen oh no you hold on
see it there there's my cloud lifter so
yeah we've got one of those
uh that is not the issue i can assure
you that was not the issue
with the uh with the microphone hunter
reed says david do you prefer the derby
or the pork pie
i don't eat pork so i'm going to go with
the derby
yeah fazegt says
it's weird trump drapes himself in
military aesthetic
while simultaneously being a draft
dodger
president bone spurs everyone's standing
now
why are people standing i'm guessing
it's because trump is about to wait
the president of the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
we're gonna stick with this stream
because i find it to generally be a
better stream and less interrupted okay
so we're going to stick with it
[Music]
by the way the idea that trump from
queens likes country music is laughable
[Music]
well thank you very much and that was
some greeting we had in north carolina
i'll tell you i don't know if you saw
the crowd outside but it's pretty
amazing
but we've had it in texas and ohio and
south carolina
florida it's just incredible what's
happening please sit down please
and i'm honored to be in north carolina
in the presence of true american heroes
as we commemorate the 75th anniversary
of the
american victory in world war ii in a
victory it was
on september 2nd 1945 prepare for trump
to draw parallels between world war
ii and him trying to get himself
reelected surrender aboard the
uss missouri in tokyo bay
vj day marked the end of the deadliest
conflict
in human history and the ultimate
triumph
of american freedom
it was a big day i was a great triumph a
great country and our country is greater
than ever before
that's what's happening and that's what
it is greater with a greater military
with a greater military than we've ever
had before
we're deeply moved to be joined this
afternoon by
world war ii veterans all of whom i've
met
all of whom are tough i don't want to
mess around with any of them i'll tell
you right now
whose blood sweat grit courage and
unfailing devotion
made that epic victory possible
these brave americans raced into the
fires of hell
to vanquish tyranny dethroned fascism
and defend the american way of life
you've earned the eternal and undying
gratitude of all americans
and that's why i'm here today i wanted
to be with you
you know what i'm talking about don't
you we had a good time a little while
ago right over at the oval office
congressional medal of honor we're
privileged to be joined as well by
veterans from every generation
including a number of wounded warriors
we stand in awe
of your service i can say that so
respected so loved
we are in awe joining us for this
commemoration our secretary david
bernhardt
secretary where is david thank you david
very much for being here
a great senator a real friend of mine a
tremendous senator actually and
he works very very hard and he loves the
people of north carolina
senator tom tillis tom thank you very
much
and some warriors they're in congress
and they're tough and they're smart
representatives
david rouser ted budd and dan bishop
thank you fellas
they are tough but you're not as tough
as these guys i'll tell you right now
right
you're not as tough as them there's no
better place to mark this profound world
war
two anniversary than right here in
wilmington north carolina
the people of this city in this state
and its incredible state and
i want to thank you for being so nice to
me you've been very nice
very very nice that's all he cares about
you've asked for something but i've been
nice to you also i have to say that
but you made the extraordinary
contributions to the
war effort that's north carolina made
this extraordinary contribution and so
many nearly 2 million americans serve
has been trained
for combat in north carolina more than
any other state
wow that's pretty good isn't it huh who
would know that
two million wow that's pretty good isn't
it huh
over 360 000 service members from your
state fought
in the second world war they battled on
the cliffs of normandy
over the skies of africa and in the deep
waters of the pacific
over 11 000 north carolina patriots
fought
the enemy until their very last
breath you know what that means right
think of that 11 000
died in the war we want to thank you boy
and we have really puts 190 k dead from
covid into perspective doesn't it
in wilmington more than 20 000 workers
of the north carolina shipbuilding
company
poured out every ounce of their strength
to build an astonishing 243
ships for the u.s navy and it was the
citizens of wilmington who came together
to save a priceless
artifact of american history the
glorious battleship behind me the uss
north carolina and that is some powerful
and beautiful ship by coming in on
coming in
we're just we got plenty of televisions
on
air force one what is it they showed it
in prime time
in the 40s and they showed that ship and
i'll tell you they don't make
i shouldn't say this they don't make
them that way anymore they really what
what a beautiful ship during world war
ii this magnificent ship
participated in many major naval
offenses
and in the pacific theater itself
including the marshall islands
iwo jima and okinawa earning more battle
stars than any
other battleship we're learning a lot
today right that's pretty good
why what trump means by that is this is
the first he's ever heard of any of this
stuff
virginia so do i right but we're
clapping anyway right
you better believe it thank you after
the war the people of wilmington
organized
as you can see my prediction of upper
trump was accurate today the scrapyard
they preserved it as a memorial to the
gallandees of american sailors a
monument to the american workers that
built it
and an enduring symbol of american
greatness now more than 200
000 people visit the site each year to
learn the history and the heroism that
defines our nation this afternoon my
administration is formally recognizing
the city's exceptional
contributions to victory in the second
world war
it is my tremendous honor
to officially designate wilmington north
carolina
as our nation's very first world war
ii heritage city that's a big deal
i don't know that that's logical no
offense to wilmington but i do think the
person earlier who said
what what about you know hawaii pearl
harbor maybe would be more rel
i'm just not sure there i tell you
we may have to go a little quicker than
i thought right
with this designation we proudly because
we know trump doesn't go out in the rain
don't tear down the past we celebrate
our heroes
we cherish our heritage we preserve our
history
and we build the future this mighty
vessel in this magnificent town will
forever tell that story
with this designation so i want to just
congratulate north carolina and
wilmington
i'm sure you guys understand that if if
trump is out in the rain
his hair will do things trump does not
want to be seen in public
doing let's put it that way that's his
concern here stand up please
the lightning bolts for their work to
make this day possible thank you tom
thank you fellas great job and let me
also thank retired navy captain wilbur
jones
who has championed the cause of world
war ii heritage cities
yeah expect trump's spray tan to be all
over his uh shirt collar if it starts
raining
great job great job so wilbur
you know a lot of people wanted this
right so you are just a tough cookie
you got it number one number one in the
nation
i want to thank wilbur that's great i
also want to recognize several of the
heroes who saved american freedom
i like how he's just paging through the
entire thing now that it's sprinkling
there they are here today is my good
friend who i just left and
he was in the oval office with me at the
white house woody williams
75 years ago woody showed fearless
courage
as a marine in the battle of iwo jima
you are amazing
[Applause]
i promised him i would not tell that
he's 97 years old i promise
i'll tell you he's 100 sharp
he's a hundred percent sharp i know a 78
year old that's not so sharp and he's
yeah
the attack on biden because has nothing
to do with that 78
trump who unprovoked denied having
multiple strokes even though nobody
alleged it is saying
joe biden's having a health issue
physically in great shape
he braved a torrent of hostile fire
while destroying one enemy machine gun
position after another knocked him out
one after one for his daring actions
president truman think of that awarded
woody the congressional medal of honor
the highest
in our land woody congratulations you
inspire us all it was great to have you
on air force one
i have promised him you know maybe two
years ago i said i'll take you on air
force when he came up
he's very aggressive he said i'd like to
fly an air force one i said i'll do it
and today we did it right we got it done
thanks woody great job trump actually
seems scared of rain i'm realizing he
seems scared world war ii
korea and vietnam during the second
world war paul proudly served on the uss
north carolina in the pacific theater
at 93 years old he has returned today to
visit the ship upon which he's so nobly
served
he's a tremendous man paul it's our
honor to have you with us please paul
stand up thank you
thank you paul stand up sit down got to
keep moving perfect
thank you paul great job paul
appreciate it here as well as army
veteran greg
melikean when greg was 20 years old he
served as a radio operator in the
headquarters of supreme allied commander
general dwight
d eisenhower i'd love to have heard some
of those conversations
much more interesting than today right
75 years ago
general eisenhower directed greg to
broadcast around the world the
long-awaited news
that germany had surrendered greg
your being here is very very much
appreciated thank you very much it was a
great honor meeting you before thank you
very much
i think the trumpists are embarrassed by
this only 4 000 people are watching this
on the white house youtube channel and
12 000 are watching it with us
in the blessings of liberty that you
fought for
and that you bled for all for security
you wanted to secure our future you
wanted to
praise and raise our flag and you did
that you raise our flag and you stand
proud and you stand tall and we're doing
it in our nation too
almost everyone every once in a while
you see somebody not do it
we don't like it when they don't do a
doing we don't like it
i want to just thank you fantastic job
american warriors did not defeat fascism
and oppression overseas only to watch
our freedoms be trampled by violent mobs
here at home
we stopped those violent mobs very
easily all they have to do is say
please come in mr president we'll have
it done in one hour
please come in it's one of the great
to me just incredible that they don't
immediately they just
as you know at portland the mayor last
night he was
raided his home was raided he was thrown
out of his home
and then he'll stand up and he'll fight
for these people these people only know
one thing
and that's strength that's all they know
strength and we have strength
for the sake of all americans we must
uphold the rule of law and defend the
american dream
for every child in our land we must
teach our children that america is the
land of heroes
like you your heroes you know that right
woody you're heroes
you're great great men
great men better believe it we're not
ashamed in america
we're not ashamed of anything i signed a
very important
edict recently three months ago they
were ripping down statues
i said you can rip them down but you're
going to serve 10 years in jail if you
do
and as soon as i do remember we already
had laws against ripping down statues
statues are monuments but we're not
ashamed
of our country we're proud of our
country prouder than we are of anything
else
our country is great and we're going to
keep it that way we're going to keep our
country great
together we will remember america's
towering victories
we will recognize america's outstanding
virtues
and we will pay tribute to the heroes
who keep us safe strong
proud and free and i also in addition to
our
wonderful brilliant military i want to
thank law enforcement
because the law enforcement without them
we're
not here today very well they've done an
incredible job
really an incredible job and thank you
again
to the world war ii veterans in
attendance today this is such a great
tribute to
north carolina we will never forget what
you did for us your legacy is etched
forever into the heart and soul of
a grateful nation and this spot is right
now
one of the most important military spots
anywhere in the world congratulations to
everybody and thank you for making it
come true thank you all very much god
bless you
god bless north carolina and god bless
america thank you all very much
oh man that's the whole thing
oh my god that's the entire event guys
what a
what a mess oh my god
uh oh is that a ramp trump has not done
so well with ramps before
uh oh no okay i see he's gonna go out
the back
was that an eight-minute speech he flew
there for that is my tax money paying
for this
what a bizarre bizarre speech
unbelievable let's see what's happening
yeah so ym's the requisite ymca going on
there
so all right donald trump getting in and
out very very quickly there
and um yeah i don't really know what to
make of it
very stupid a very stupid event i can
tell you
with complete and total certainty and
yes yes
donald trump humiliating himself what a
surprise
what a surprise okay that's gonna do it
for me i do have a pog
champs chess match at 5 east
to west today you can find me
i won't be streaming but it'll it'll be
on the chess.com twitch account
and any number of other accounts so i
will see you guys then
thank you for joining me as the crowd
heading for the hills very very quickly
here thank you
you